welcome everyone welcome welcome to the
Yale School of Nursing bellos lecture I
am very very honored to introduce our
speaker for today
it gives me absolutely enormous pleasure
to introduce dr. Margaret Hamburg as the
2018 Sibyl Palmer Bellis lecture speaker
dr. Hamburg has a wealth of experience
in both public health and medicine and
is a world-renowned leader an advocate
in those areas and others and just talk
about leadership listen to her CV she
served as the 21st Commissioner of Food
and Drug Administration she was the only
the second woman ever to head that
agency under her almost six years of
leadership there dr. Hamburg oversaw the
modernisation of a food safety system to
reduce food borne illness the
advancement of biomedical innovation
through the approval of novel medical
products in cutting-edge areas of
science and medicine the securing of a
safer globalized food and medical
product supply chain and the
implementation of the Family Smoking
Prevention and Tobacco Control Act to
reduce the death and disease caused by
tobacco prior to her time at the FDA dr.
Hamburg was a founding member of the
nuclear threat initiative a foundation
dedicated to reducing the threat to
public safety from nuclear chemical and
biological weapons as the Foundation's
vice-president for biological programs
she advocated for broad reforms to
confront the dangers of modern
bioterrorism as well as the threats of
naturally-occurring infectious diseases
such as pandemic flu and sadly this work
is still all too relevant dr. Hamburg's
previous government positions include
assistant secretary for planning and
evaluation at the US Department of
Health and Human Services Health
Commissioner for the city of New York
and assistant director of the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases at the National instance of
Health dr. Hamburg currently serves as
foreign secretary of the national
academy of medicine where she is the
senior advisor on international matters
and the liaison with other academies of
medicine around the world and if I'm
right Peggy I believe you're the only
mother father daughter member of the
national kind of medicine is that
correct yeah
fabulous additionally she's
president-elect of the American
Association for the Advancement of
science the world's largest
multidisciplinary scientific society and
a leading publisher of cutting-edge
research through its science family of
journals furthermore dr. Hamburg sits on
the boards of the Commonwealth Fund the
Simons Foundation the Urban Institute
the Global Alliance for vaccines and
immunization the Parker Institute for
cancer immunotherapy and the American
Museum of Natural History
she's chair of the joint coordinating
group for the Coalition for epidemic
preparedness and innovation and a member
of the Harvard University global
Advisory Council the global health
scientific advisory committee for the
Gates Foundation the Harvard Medical
School Board of fellows and the world
dementia Council are you tired
yes you should be this religion to that
dr. Hamburg hails from family family
background in medicine her parents are
both physicians and leaders in their
field of mental health and nice story
they met at Yale School of Medicine her
mother Beatrix is a notable American
psychiatrist and the first African
American woman to graduate from Vassar
College now led of course by our own
Betsy Bradley who was last year's Ballas
lecture on so and the Yale School of
Medicine dr. Hamburg is an alumna of
Radcliffe College Harvard Medical School
and is the recipient of course of
multiple honorary degrees and numerous
awards it goes without saying dr.
Hamburg has truly led a distinguished
career and we're thrilled to have her
here today please join me in welcoming
her
well thank you so much for that very
generous introduction and thank you for
inviting me to join you here today it
really is a pleasure to be here to honor
the memory of Sibyl Palmer Bayliss
for whom this lecture is named to honor
the much esteemed Yale School of Nursing
and also to really take a moment to
reflect on the really great tradition
and future of Nursing as a profession as
was noted I do have some yeld
connections I like to come to Yale I've
never studied or worked here but I have
been involved you know first of all you
you noted that my mother was the first
African American to go to Vassar she was
actually the first African American
woman to come to Yale Medical School so
that also is another pioneering
connection to the school my parents met
here and maybe most significantly my
daughter was an undergraduate here and
she's now a first year at Yale Law
School so I was just saying it's pretty
easy to get me to come to Yale but that
isn't why I'm here I'm really here
because of the importance of Nursing the
extraordinary leadership of Dean Kurth
and I think the opportunities to really
talk about Nursing in the modern world
and and to reflect a bit on on weird
Nursing has been and also where Nursing
can go and importantly this is really a
school with a long and remarkable
tradition I I didn't actually understand
about this campus I was gonna walk from
the study and and very generously
offered to have me be met and I thought
well that's sort of overkill but when I
learned that it was actually five miles
and crossing some major highways I was
glad to have the ride but I kind of
liked this setting I mean both it's
beautiful and sort of
and contemplative in many ways but but
also the symbolism of a research campus
where there's been research going on and
opportunities to think about discovery
but also the importance of the School of
Nursing is the crucible through which
both additional research is done but
also it's translated out to the people
and communities need I was very struck
as I was preparing for this speech about
the history of this school really
beginning with your first Dean who I
understand is often referred to as the
mother of nursing education
Annie Warburton Goodrich and I think her
vision was really very true and just as
relevant today as it was then
emphasizing the importance of social
justice and community integration within
the curriculum and a goal to educate
future nurses to be fine typically
informed technically expert and socially
experienced but in many ways her
approach really built on an even older
foundation of the nursing profession the
tradition of caring as well as curing a
framework of vital importance I think
when we look to the challenges before us
today and also as we reflect on some of
the greatest medical and public health
challenges of the fact of the past and
mentioned my involvement with infectious
disease threats and some of you may know
that this year marks the hundredth
anniversary of one of the most
devastating health threats in human
history the great flu pandemic of 1918
in just 11 months a wave of death
crashed around the globe
killing somewhere between 50 to a
hundred million individuals one third of
humanity was infected and those in the
prime of life were actually the most at
risk because they mounted a very robust
immune response but it wasn't just the
magnitude of the pandemic it was also
the ferocity many sickened and died in a
single day drowning as their lungs
filled with fluid or turning blue and
coughing so violently that it actually
ruptured their abdominal muscles here at
Yale interestingly the university placed
itself under a virtual quarantine I
understand it passed out gauze masks and
tried to isolate students and faculty
from the growing threat outside Phelps
gate the strategy seemed to work
I don't know but amazingly Yale
reportedly lost only three students to
the pandemic but beyond the Gothic walls
of Yale nearly 800 residents of New
Haven died as the pandemic raged society
began to crumble in every stricken
community there was no vaccination no
treatment no cure but there was one
small spark of hope as Wilmer cruson
director of the Department of Public
Health and charities in Philadelphia
which was actually the city hardest hit
by the pandemic declared if you would
ask me three things
Philadelphia most needs to conquer the
epidemic I would tell you
nurses more nurses and yet more nurses
he was right and researched by dr. Arlen
Keeling of the University of Virginia
who studied the history of Nursing in
the 1918 pandemic wrote in the journal
Public Health reports that excellent
nursing care was the primary treatment
for influenza during the pandemic in
fact whether it overcrowded hospitals or
emergency aid stations in teeming City
tenements or isolated frontier cabins
for the ill their families their
neighbors the communities good nursing
care was the single best predictor of
outcome in 1918 nurses were the
essential element in combating an
unprecedented global health challenge
specifically it was the tradition of
professional nursing that made the
difference
the tradition of combining knowledge
practical skill and patient centered
values the tradition of concern for the
whole person their environment their
community and an understanding of their
interconnection the tradition of not
just treating a disease but of truly
for a patient or a population this I
think was also very much the tradition
of civil Palmer bellows who worked with
immigrant families in New York and for
whom this lecture is named and is
precisely this tradition combined with
Dean goodrich's goal that nurses be
scientifically informed technically
expert and socially experienced that
will allow today's nurses to meet some
of the most important health challenges
now before us and this afternoon I want
to talk about three of those challenges
combating disease creating greater
health equity and caring for the planet
I also want to discuss the role that
nurses continue to play in addressing
these challenges whether working at the
patient bedside in the halls of academia
or the streets of a community and
finally I want to offer a call to action
that must be answered if we want to
advance and promote the tradition of
Nursing for the betterment of all our
first challenge is to combat disease and
that includes communicable or infectious
disease non communicable or chronic
disease and what some have called
communicated disease so let me first
start with communicable there was a time
which didn't seem so long ago when we
thought that we might actually be
removing communicable or infectious
disease from the headlines and
consigning it to the history books and
believe it or not as a first-year
student at Harvard Medical School maybe
this wasn't truly Yale but I actually
did hear that or at least that the
future of medicine was really going to
be chronic disease the advent of
antibiotics and vaccines that were
effective obviously gave us great hope
and there certainly has been real
progress made smallpox once a
devastating disease around the globe has
been eradicated polio seems close to
elimination certainly we've seen serious
childhood killers like measles and
diphtheria become rare events in this
country and in many others as well
although not entirely forgotten sadly
but we've also
mean serious infectious disease threats
persist with third and new ones emerged
truthfully it was watching the hiv/aids
epidemic emerge as a medical student
that made me decide to pursue a career
in health policy and public service
rather than the academic career that I
had always planned and the threat of
terrorism which declared itself as a
serious domestic concern here in the US
really back in 1993 when the first
bombing of the World Trade Center in New
York City occurred and I was then health
commissioner that made me start to think
about microbes not just as agents of
illness and disease but also as
potential agents of war and terror today
we recognize that the spectrum of
infectious disease is ever-expanding
with new previously unknown diseases
appearing and taking hold as well as the
re-emergence of old diseases sometimes
in new and more dangerous forms thanks
to inappropriate antibiotic use in many
cases and also to other pressures and
the fact is that even with all of the
miracles of modern medicine
we don't always have the antibiotics and
vaccines that we need we know that we
live in an increasingly globalized world
with very porous borders with travel and
trade we're increasingly interconnected
a disease anywhere can be a disease
everywhere and changing patterns of
agriculture urbanization and of course
climate change and environmental
degradation are all increasing risks for
infectious disease we also know that a
pandemic flu like that of 1918 can and
most likely will happen again influenza
pandemics have regularly slept swept the
world about once in a generation and
that's why we were all so alarmed back
in 2009 if you remember when a swine flu
outbreak h1n1 emerged in Mexico it
ultimately caused some 17,000 deaths
worldwide but it was much less virulent
than originally feared
and some of us were plenty worried this
past flu season when the flu unfolded in
a form that was much more vicious and
much more lethal than we had expected
but of course it's about much more than
just flu the next pandemic may be an
outbreak of an emerging infectious
disease or a malicious attack using a
microbe or an inadvertent laboratory
outbreak or the re-emergence of any
number of old adversaries such as
antibiotic resistant tuberculosis and
that was my first exposure to that set
of issues when I was health commissioner
in New York City when I took office in
the early 1990s the number of patients
with tuberculosis had more than tripled
and we had a huge unexpected percentage
of cases with drug-resistant
tuberculosis in response we designed one
of the most comprehensive tuberculosis
control programs ever focusing on both
prevention and treatment and working
well beyond the confines of hospitals
and clinics to reach patients wherever
they were and with this approach we were
eventually able to both meet and beat
this serious unfolding threat when it
comes to fighting infectious disease the
key as we saw in New York is ensuring a
comprehensive continuum of disease
prevention diagnosis response and
management we must not be afraid but we
must be aware and we must be prepared
and we must work as partners across
traditional boundaries of professional
disciplines sectors and even borders and
of course nurses are a vital part of the
comprehensive work to fight infectious
disease this was certainly true in our
fight to control TB in New York City
working on healthcare teams they
provided unique understanding of health
care delivery necessary resources
infection prevention management and
control and in the best tradition of
Nursing the very human and
ballistic needs of patients that we
simply could not overlook and when it
really gets tough it's often the nurses
who are in the lead I saw that in New
York City and is noted it was a hallmark
of the 1918 pandemic flu we saw it again
when the world witnessed one of our many
wake-up calls about the threat of
infectious disease in our modern world
the unexpected emergence and spread of
severe acute respiratory syndrome or
SARS that outbreak declared itself
powerfully in Hong Kong back in 2003 and
the nursing profession was widely noted
to have played really an extraordinary
role public health nurses went into
communities and traced contacts provided
education to the public obtained samples
took health histories allayed fears and
addressed the depression that was
actually a striking concomitant of the
SARS disease and served on research
teams in related case control studies
and participated in investigation and
surveillance they really helped care
both for patients and for entire
populations SARS would eventually spread
most notably to Canada were really took
an unexpectedly heavy toll and of course
demonstrated vividly that infectious
disease recognizes no boundaries or
borders but as we think about threats to
health in the modern era we must
recognize that it's not only
communicable infectious disease that can
transcend borders and were meaningful
solutions require us to think and act in
more comprehensive ways I want to
mention dr. gros Brundtland who was the
director-general of the World Health
Organization during the SARS outbreak
and she later put in place a
comprehensive system called the
international health regulations to
strengthen systems for infectious
disease prevention and control but she
was also deeply concerned about another
class of disease that she liked to call
communicated disease and sadly she was
really prescient but
you negated disease she was referring to
the large and growing burden of disease
associated with so-called lifestyle
issues or behavioral risk factors
including smoking poor nutrition and
lack of exercise in many ways these are
transmitted or communicated across
communities and across nations through
marketing and advertising for unhealthy
products such as junk food sugary
beverages and cigarettes they are
transcending boundaries because of how
culture spreads through the media TV
movies etc and because the increasingly
global nature of our lives and these
health problems really a subset of
chronic disease are very much global
problems diabetes for example is a
leading cause of death and disability in
this country and around the world and
unfortunately the rates of diabetes
particularly type 2 diabetes are rising
very significantly we know that diabetes
is a complex chronic disease that's
closely tied to conditions of overweight
and obesity and an article in Lancet
last year warned that rising levels of
increasingly severe obesity means that
worldwide populations are in the brink
of a catastrophic epidemic of diabetes
and we're all too familiar with its
devastating complications and the
significant toll that takes on the lives
of individuals families and our
healthcare systems and as with other
so-called communicated diseases
effectively combating diabetes relies on
treating disease and managing symptoms
but also on addressing both behavioral
risk factors and socio-economic
determinants of health and once again
nurses drawing on their tradition of
caring and curing our key in prevention
and treatment efforts certainly a
disease like diabetes illustrates the
value and often central importance of
nurses across the whole
spectrum they're central to the medical
care of patients acute care along with
more routine clinical management of
symptoms and complications but it's also
the occupational health nurses public
health nurses and school nurses who may
be the primary providers of patient
education coaching about self-care
strategies direction advice and often
most important support and unlike their
physician colleagues I will admit I
think it's fair to say that nurses are
much more likely to recognize and
address the socio-economic factors that
can so affect a person's health we're
increasingly aware that the context of
people's lives determines their house as
much as genetics and other intrinsic
biology factors such as physical
environment including safe water clean
air and healthy workplaces Homes and
Communities income level educational
opportunities social support services
and networks access to health services
and nutritious food transportation
options and cultural sensitivities are
all very significant determinants of
health of individuals and of communities
and I know that Betsy Bradley who gave
last year's lecture address some of
these issues when she spoke to you last
year and I'm sure that she understood
that those in the nursing profession
using their you unique education and
skills their tradition values and
approach are among the most qualified to
help us all rethink our framework in
terms of how to best address health and
to better address and integrate this
vital reality it's not a coincidence
that so many care managers and primary
care practices are nurses and why
they're essential partners in public
health and community development efforts
to create a culture of health and
well-being in patients daily lives and
this is why in a setting like this one
academic nursing can play a formative
role in undertaking the research and
training
which must transcend the traditional
boundaries of medical care to better
prepare us to meet the challenges we
face and in preparing the cadre of new
leaders and practitioners that we so
need for the future these of course are
not trivial things and can have a
profound effect on a patient facing a
range of diseases and will become even
more important as our population ages
across all ages as well as we see the
burden of chronic disease increase and
that burden is high in the u.s. we know
that seven of the top causes of death
are chronic diseases with about half of
all American adults having at least one
chronic condition and one in four adults
with two or more chronic health
conditions and approximately 71% of all
US healthcare spending is on people with
multiple chronic conditions and globally
chronic disease accounts for 70% of all
deaths are some forty million people
each year and of that many of those
chronic disease deaths particularly the
ones occurring in the age group of about
30 to 69 are occurring in low and middle
income countries we tend to think of
infectious disease as the source of more
burden in those countries chronic
disease a problem of developed countries
like ours but in fact chronic disease
really is a predominant threat around
the world today and it's a threat we can
only address if we adopt novel and
innovative policies programs and
interventions and not surprisingly
around the world we're seeing nurses
come forward with innovative programs
many of which address chronic disease
outside of clinic walls with improved
patient care satisfaction and lower
costs one program that I learned about
only recently but some of you may be
more familiar about it is called Bert's
org meaning neighborhood care and it
actually developed in the Netherlands
with a nurse led holistic approach and I
just want to mention it quickly because
I think
it's important to understand some of the
elements that have made it successful it
began actually back in 2006 when a
district nurse gross diblock became
frustrated with a model of home care
that was very fragmented that had
multiple caregivers doing discrete tasks
being paid by the task and by the hour
not serving patients well and not being
very efficient either so he created a
system where nurses could work in teams
caring for everyone in a given
neighborhood directly responsive and
accountable to local patients and
families and providing comprehensive
medical care and support services that
cut across traditional boundaries of
work and disciplines and this
patient-centered care really in the best
tradition of Nursing was driven by
patient's needs and wishes and by the
knowledge of the nurses who cared for
them and it turns out that compared to
other home care organizations and
programs in the Netherlands Bert Zog has
achieved better outcomes better health
and the highest rates of satisfaction
from patients anywhere in the
Netherlands and it's saving money and I
think the elements that make it
successful go back to this application
of the nurses own knowledge practical
skills and experience working in
interdisciplinary ways breaking down
barriers that interfered with care and
with health and establishing real trust
between the patient and the healthcare
providers and you know again this goes
back to the traditions of Nursing really
the crux of the nursing tradition and I
think nicely sums up the importance of
nurses to combating disease whatever its
complexity and whatever its cause and of
course the tradition of Nursing is also
a prescription for so much that ails our
healthcare system beyond just combating
disease one of those Alma
is inequity in health creating greater
health equity and eliminating health
disparities is another of the big
challenges that I want to discuss with
you today it's sobering to look at some
of the statistics from a global
perspective according to the w-h-o last
year a child born in Sierra Leone can
expect to live for 50 years while a
child in Japan can live to 84 87 percent
of premature deaths due to chronic
disease occur in low and middle-income
countries in developing countries
account for I'm told 99 percent of
annual maternal deaths around the world
although that struck me is a little high
but I know that this is an area of
particular interest to Yale especially
given the incredible depth of midwife
midwifery expertise that's on your
faculty and in your your training and
research programs but I want to stress
that inequalities are often just too
stark within countries in the US for
example African Americans represent only
about 3 percent of the population but
account for 50 percent of all new HIV
infections and sometimes geography is
destiny even within a city in London
when traveling east from Westminster
each tube stop represents nearly one
year of lost life expectancy according
to the London Health Observatory so a
few miles apart on the Underground may
be miles apart in terms of health and
longevity and here in the US a series of
maps that were developed by the Center
on society and health at Virginia
Commonwealth University a project funded
by the RWJ foundation back in 2016 show
that life expectancy can differ by as
much as 20 years in neighborhoods only
about 5 miles apart from one another you
know really quite extraordinary but you
know not a surprise certainly when I was
health commissioner in New York City in
the 1990s you know I - observed that
there were great gaps between
neighborhoods with the worst rates of
infant mortality HIV TB and more all
layering
one on top of the other in some of our
poorest communities so if we truly don't
want community cities even the global
community divided by separate but
unequal parts and I believe we really
must work together to address this huge
concern first we must do more to prevent
disease in underserved communities that
includes effectively reaching out and
getting the right information to the
right people in the right way an
increasing scientific research that
explores risk factors in these
communities we must enable access to
health care by removing physical social
legislative cultural and especially
financial barriers and we must ensure
culturally sensitive care which also
means communicating across divides of
race social class education and
attitudes of course to achieve these
things to create greater equity and
health it's once again nurses that are
so very often on the front lines nurses
and midwives account for more than 50%
of the global health workforce and in
the developing world they're often the
only health provider that someone may
see additionally as I just noted nurses
working in the community are best able
to assess the many factors that may
hinder health to engage community
strengths and to ensure culturally
sensitive care and whether it's locally
or globally it's nurses who are often
the catalysts and change agents in
reducing health inequality and as we
work to achieve health equity we have
another task before us perhaps one of
even greater long-term dimension in
proportion and this is the third big
challenge that I want to discuss caring
for the planet by advancing planetary
health and I know that this is an area
of focus and activity that Dean Kurth
has been deeply committed to and if we
care about the future I think that all
of us must engage it was in 1993 that
norwegian physician
per food jelly raised an important alarm
about planetary health when he wrote
that the patient earth is sick global
environmental disruptions can have
serious consequences for human health 21
years later a commentary in the March
2014 issue of Lancet called for the
creation of a movement for planetary
health and they then joined the
Rockefeller Foundation in a commission
which in 2015 released a seminal report
with a rather obscure title safeguarding
human health in the Anthropocene epoch
the report explored the scientific basis
for creating planetary health as a new
field and I found it quite compelling as
you may know this new field goes beyond
our current global health framework to
take into account the natural systems on
which human health depends it formally
recognizes the link between human caused
destruction of Earth's ecosystems and
the resulting impacts on public health
and above all it holds that to protect
the health of people populations here
and around the world we must
fundamentally address the health of the
biosphere and in my view if we overlook
the need for a planetary health movement
we will do so at our peril it's true the
global achievements in health
agriculture and Industry have ensured
that we're living longer and better
lives in many ways although as I just
noted grave disparities continue to
exist but unfortunately we also know
that our tremendous socio-economic
progress has taken a toll on the life of
our planet we need only look quickly at
some of the evidence the climate is
warming almost half of all tropical
forests and a fifth of all coral reefs
have been lost
thanks to fertilizer runoff the Gulf of
Mexico's dead zone is now twice the size
of the Chesapeake Bay and two-thirds of
the world may face water shortages by 20
25 and I have found it sort of startling
to read about the problems in Cape Town
South Africa today where they may run
out of water by next year so in the end
this matters for all of us our health
our safety our well-being and ultimately
our lives any complacency that we feel
about planetary health I think should be
replaced with the sense of urgency and
in particular the Landsat Rockefeller
report outlines three tasks for the
global community first to address
conceptual and empathy failures such as
an over reliance on GDP as a measure of
human progress we must address knowledge
failures such as historical historical
scarcity of transdisciplinary research
and funding and third implementation
failures such as the failure of
governments and institutions to
recognize and respond to threats in a
timely fashion or to ignore scientific
fact in favor of political expediency
and I know that Yale is already working
to tackle many of these issues and all
of the embedded complexities as part of
the planetary health Alliance which is a
consortium of over 95 universities NGOs
government entities and other global
organizations funded by the Rockefeller
Foundation and dedicated to advancing
planetary health and I think that the
Alliance will clearly benefit greatly
from all of the assets of Yale
University across its many schools and
and experts its depth in in health
science policy and management so caring
for the planet creating greater health
equity combating disease there is a lot
to be done but mobilizing the talent
training and commitment of the nursing
profession will be vital to meeting all
these challenges and I don't think I
need to tell you that this is a critical
time for Nursing to improve health
around all these issues and and so many
levels we must work to strengthen
and to ensure its proper role and I know
that many of you in the room are much
more deeply involved with these issues
than I but let me offer quickly a few
thoughts before I close first I'm struck
maybe this is because I work part time
at the National Academy of Medicine what
used to be the Institute of Medicine but
we must continue to pursue the
recommendations of the landmark
Institute of Medicine report second we
must strengthen and extend the global
nursing workforce and third in the
immortal words of Rodney Dangerfield we
must always ensure that nurses in every
field and every capacity receive the
respect they deserve so let me just
quickly briefly elaborate on some of
these points I'll begin with the IOM
report written back in 2010 almost a
decade ago and mainly aimed at us nurses
but I think that its its recommendations
are relevant for the global nursing
concern and they're also still extremely
timely there's also I think merit and
sort of looking at what progress has
been made they had that report had four
key messages that nurses should practice
to the full extent of their education
and training the nurses should achieve
higher levels of education and training
through an improved education system
that promotes seamless academic
progression this is one probably of
particular relevance to the community
here at Yale as I understand it this was
actually the first School of Nursing
within a university and with the degree
that actually met the standards of the
University and I think this really began
a tradition of cutting-edge improvement
and constant advancement in nursing
education you know really emanating here
from Yale the IOM third message in the
report was that nurses should be full
partners with physicians and other
health care professionals in redesigning
our whole system of healthcare in the
United State
and forth that effective workforce
planning and policy making requires
better data collection and an improved
information infrastructure so these were
all good recommendations but the
question is have they made a difference
have they been acted on what remains to
be done and what new concerns or
perspectives have emerged I think we all
know that too many good reports just sit
on shelves and I was glad that a few
years ago the IOM actually convened a
committee to assess progress and
encouragingly there were some striking
accomplishments in the interest of time
I think I won't go through those but to
say that in each of the major domains
measurable progress has been made at the
state level at the federal level and in
terms of advancing nursing education but
there is still much more to be done the
steps that have been made our steps to
build on not steps to rest on and I
think you know once again this
institution importantly can help to lead
on many of the issues and your voices
all matter as advocates to continue to
advance this important agenda I also
think that if you want to strengthen the
nursing then clearly advancing
recommendations like those that were in
the IOM report is really important but
we also have to think not just about
needs in our country which that report
mainly focused on not just about
advancing conditions of practice
education and training but how do we
extend the reach of nurses really to
every corner of the world that needs it
and really think with a globalized view
and nursing is clearly a global
profession and you know I think as part
of that we really have to think about
what can we do to ensure a better global
distribution of nurses in 2013 the w-h-o
estimated that might point
35 the world will be short 12 point 9
million health care workers importantly
including nurses is a very large
fraction of those health care workers
and representing the vast majority of
providers I saw one statistic I wasn't
going to use it because I couldn't quite
believe it which is that while nurses
represent 50% of the global healthcare
workforce nursing services actually
represent 90% of services worldwide it
it's striking if true and it may well be
true because the critical role that
nurses play and the the mountain
distribution of the health care
workforce is is really very striking in
a 2017 report the US and Canada
comprised 14% of the world's population
and 10% of the global disease burden but
had 30% of the global health workforce
in contrast sub-saharan Africa with 11%
of the world's population and 24% of the
disease burden had only 3% of the global
health workforce including nurses and
unfortunately given population trends
the problem will only be exacerbated no
doubt and we know that the shortages are
also being not just a reflection of
population growth which is very true but
also the out-migration of health care
workers nurses very much included from
developing countries to developed
countries and that is a trend that that
has been going on for many years and
it's continuing you know really
compromising in many ways the health
care workforce in those countries of
origin and creating an ongoing nursing
brain drain I also want to mention
probably no surprise to you that the MAL
distribution of nurses is also
exacerbated by entropy country
disparities between urban centers and
rural regions and that is true in
developing nation
as well as in our own country
significant urban rural disparities
exist with rural areas tending to have
lower levels of staffing resulting in
less access and poorer clinical outcomes
so once again whether between countries
or between communities geography may be
destiny but it shouldn't have to be that
way and we really need to evaluate new
models and policies that will address
the MAL distribution of nurses so we can
strengthen the reach and impact of
Nursing around the world and one last
thing that I think we really must do
successfully to answer a call to action
to strengthen Nursing something that may
seem simple and obvious but requires our
focused attention and hard work and this
is that we must ensure that the enormous
contribution of nurses to improving
health around the globe is accurately
understood and appropriately respected
and supported I had a crash course in
the importance of Nursing back in my
days as a medical resident working in
intensive care unit that was a while ago
but given the seriousness of the
illnesses that we were dealing with and
the complexity of the technology it was
the nurses that we relied on that we
turn to who frankly prevented us from
becoming completely overwhelmed and
without in the work of that intensive
care unit you know probably would have
come to a stop and I dread to think what
would have happened to the to the
patients that's obviously a very special
circumstances but so many of us in
different ways in different contexts
have have seen and experienced the
critical role of Nursing whether
providing and managing care engaging
with communities or promoting public
health nurses really are the most
important link in our health care system
moreover in many places around the world
they're off in the first and sometimes
the only health care provider that an
individual will see truly nurses are
best able to connect communicate and
coordinate across departments and
agencies disciplines professional
perspectives competing priorities and
the needs and concerns of patients
paradoxically though nurses are often
undervalued and unable to work to their
full potential additionally there's a
paucity of nurse leaders in key areas so
they lack the ability to directly
influence policy and affect
decision-making in critical ways despite
the fact that their understanding and
insights and experience in fact position
them uniquely to make a difference that
would matter to our our system of health
care and to patients so we can and must
do better as one of the great icons of
modern medicine dr. William Osler once
noted the trained nurse has become one
of the great blessings of humanity and
he said that a long time ago but I think
it's true today and I think that people
and populations around the world would
certainly agree but it's more than that
nurses are a blessing of humanity
because now more than ever humanity
needs nurses and now is the time to act
on that knowledge now is the time to
raise the status profile and
capabilities of Nursing locally and
globally now is the time to celebrate
the many contributions that Nursing has
made to promoting health and caring for
disease since the professions very
inception and now is the time to
recognize and act and the fact that the
future progress against the great
challenges before us including so many
of the things I've talked about today
combating disease creating greater
health equity and
caring for the planet as well as other
challenges emerging on our healthcare
landscape will depend on the strength
and full engagement of nurses so I'm
confident with its rich tradition of
education training research and service
here at the Yale School of Nursing and
now with the incredible vision
leadership and energy I might add of
Dean curse that the faculty the
outstanding faculty and students here at
this great institution will be at the
forefront of these efforts and will help
really to lead us all to the world in
which we want to live the world in which
we will be able to not just survive but
to thrive so thank you for having me
here today to giving me the time and the
honour to reflect on some of these
important issues thank you
you want me so very eloquent and
affirming and also just wanted to say
given how well you grasp the framework
and ethos yes for me I I just don't know
how to help the public with the image of
the person it just seems like I mean I
didn't I had high school and my office
this week doing the science project
there's going to be an oncologist you
don't have to change you
or trying to
that what you might be able to see well
yeah she's a living great tool doing
this she's cut we keep getting new
system yeah no it's it's true and and I
don't you know really have answers but I
think it is important to to get your
stories out there it's important to
bring to people's you know deeper
awareness the role that nurses are
playing in their communities in their
clinics and their hospitals and I think
you know for me you know one of the
things that was great about being asked
to do this lecture was that it made me
go back and really you know number one
think about nursing as a profession both
its history its current role in its
future but also to recognize wow I mean
I I probably was a little heavy on some
of the history but I was really
impressed I hadn't really understood how
central nurses were in all these various
roles and my my story about the ICU was
absolutely true and it was a joke
amongst the medical residents that if it
weren't for the nurses you know we'd all
be toast and the patients would be worse
but but you know there is this sort of
notion I mean you know we live in a
society I don't know enough I haven't
actually worked
in clinical settings overseas or
community settings enough to you know
really know if the perception of Nursing
is different but here you know we we we
do have a medical system that is
organized around doctors and I think
that's true more broadly in fact I will
confess that one reason why I ended up
becoming a physician besides the fact
that both my parents were physicians and
almost everyone I knew was the doctor
growing up on the Stanford campus I took
a year as a undergraduate to work at the
World Health Organization
I was gonna work on a cross-cultural
study of depression the first one they
had ever done and to my astonishment
both because I didn't have any kind of
degree at all and it's a very
hierarchical place and they had a
secretarial pool I quickly became not a
research assistant but a secretary and
it was back in the days when there
everything had to be done on a
typewriter in triplicate with the blue
form that went here in a yellow form
that went there and I'd never learned to
type because I never wanted to be a
secretary so that was miserable number
one but I also realized that that even
in that setting the World Health
Organization that you couldn't really
sit at the table if you weren't a
physician and you know I'd been thinking
about wanting to do something in in in
medicine at that point but I hadn't
really shaped you know my thinking
entirely but I was very struck you know
a physician and and that is a mindset
unfortunately that you know has
organized how we think about healthcare
people you know so I think we've got to
break that down we've got to help people
understand who's doing the real work and
also build the case I would point you
towards a new activity that's called
nursing now I don't know if you're
familiar with it and in fact I was going
to suggest that your your lecturer next
year might be done by a particular
individual who I'll talk to you about
who I think is extraordinary who's a
nurse that you know embodies all of the
best characteristics but also you know
is now an advocate for nursing around
the world but this program is really
trying to to put a focus on on the the
role and and needed contributions of
Nursing and I think it's gonna make some
difference but anyway a long answer to
say that I don't really know but there
are you know especially in this country
cultural stereotypes that work against
the nursing profession I hate to say it
but I think it's it's true you know I
wasn't joking when I said
you know I don't think you get enough
respect but you know how to make that
change I'm worrying about a parallel
issue in terms of how to get the public
and policymakers to better understand
the importance of science science in
their lives
science informed policy as we move
forward to address big challenge and
it's the same kind of thing
everybody loves nurses if you poll the
American people I'm sure new nurses are
very high in terms of trust and
appreciation but how do we get that to
translate into a broader set of needs in
terms of education and training and
support for the nursing profession and
the appropriate role across its many
dimensions and importantly getting more
nurse leaders into critical
decision-making positions I think if L
can make one contribution
it may be breeding that next cadre of
nurse leaders who will be working in
different settings but but creating a
new image of nurses for the people
around them and and bringing the
perspective of the nursing profession to
the decision-making table competent
generalist that being valued as much
well you know I think that everything
seems to go in cycles and I think that
you know what you just said was true but
I actually think that our understanding
of what matters for health how we shape
a health care system that really matters
the recognition that not everything that
matters for health happens within a
clinic or a hospital setting
will reinvigorate an appreciation for
the role of Public Health nursing for
the role of community-based programs and
services you know if we're going to make
a real difference to improve our health
status indicators in this country and
improve the quality of care in this
country we have to have a different way
of thinking and it's not just those
direct clinical health services but it's
also the ability to to go to the
community level like the the Burt's AAG
and and and link the the health and
medical care issues to other critical
services and supports other connections
etc so I have some hope but I think you
know again you know we this isn't a time
when people can sit back rest on laurels
or pontificate about what's needed this
is a time to get out and act so every
IOM report I don't know if you remember
this this is now I think history but
used to begin with a quote from the poet
philosopher Goethe which was knowledge
isn't not enough we must do willing is
not enough we must act and I always sort
of find myself cycling back to that
because you know sometimes especially in
an academic setting and often in a
government setting you know we talk a
lot but now is the time for action
well I think that's great and I do think
you know that reaching out early is
great I also you know a lot of people
come talk to me now about you know
wanting career advice and they want to
be you know active in the medical field
but they they don't you know frankly
want to put in the time of going to
medical school and residency training
and all of that but they don't think
about nursing as an alternative pathway
and I think how to actually make people
understand that you can have an equally
dynamic and impactful career and that
you don't just have to think about being
a doctor and despite what I said about
the World Health Organization yeah yeah
because I don't think it's a pathway
that I mean there's something sort of I
mean I dare I say it sort of
old-fashioned and the way many people
think about about Nursing you know and I
also think that maybe I mean I'm sure
that there's a community of nursing
schools and your Dean's talk to each
other and faculty in different areas
talk to each other but you're starting
to share models that that may work you
know cross fertilizing is also probably
a good idea but I hate that we now
actually live in a world where celebrity
makes a difference but you know you also
might need to find some celebrity nurses
I was thinking about this when I was
learning about this program that I
mentioned nursing now but it was
actually launched by Kate Middleton and
she gave a very compelling speech about
I guess that her her she has a lot of
nurses and her family she's she's not a
nursery self but you know if she talked
about you know how much she admired the
profession and and the difference that
people made and then her nurse midwife
that had delivered her baby Charlotte
happened to be in the audience and they
you know found each other and you know
and she talked about the the power of
that relationship and I was thinking you
know need a few more celebrities to to
speak to the power and importance of
Nursing
[Music]
[Music]
and observed a nurse practitioner that's
actually the role I want to be and it
wasn't about smart enough
all right wow that looks beautiful shall
I open it now okay yes I want to thank
them too
oh yeah so this is from this is
planetary health respecting a beech tree
from the law school so little in it oh
how wonderful
amazing well that's great well that
means a great deal to me well thank you
thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]